okay four people are joining the live
stream this is some late-breaking
material for version 12 of language a
few details that we are working on the
first direction of wind vectors okay I
can't imagine what this is okay yes the
perm here is that wind direction is
always reported indicating the direction
the wind is coming from so right now
when we represent an arrow representing
our a wind vector wind your vector we
are pointing the arrow towards the
direction it comes from which is rather
confusing I see I see I see I see so
when the wind direction is reported okay
so when vector data is reporting the
direction the wind is coming from
exactly so we want to disambiguate that
and there's a suggestion further down on
how to do it which is separating the
technical notation upwind ear vector and
downwind your vector then we meaning
towards the direction it flows to up
will be in the direction it comes from
so explicitly needs to need to ask the
one you want so so went back today -
what would a default - right now it's
returning a vector pointing which is a
list point in the direction it comes
from and wind direction gives you the
bearing it comes from
so try wind direction for example when
direction data for yeah I don't know
well I was trying to decide some place
where I can figure out where it actually
um it's not very windy here right now
okay and so the wind direction vector
icy wind vector data
well maybe we made a mistake him wind
vector data well we have been discussing
this and if you go to any piece of
literature or other Wikipedia page etc
they immediately say we need to report
the direction it comes from and they
give some arguments like a northerly
wind is a is a cold wind right so you
are interested in where is the wind
coming from because it will bring
humidity or whatever from that place but
reversed back to direction so if I take
the arctan um so it has to reverse so
that that notation is latitude versus
longitude okay so yes so these are
reported it should work with Claire
it's a quantity so you okay that's a bug
a Nocturn right yes in the different
different work okay right so I well it's
10 degrees off right why am i confused I
mean it might have changed I suppose so
no I think we are hitting here separate
issue okay yeah I think this is due to
the changes we have done for this yes I
remember this so Jason Jason flipped
these sorry
it's very unconvincing I'm looking out
the window there is some breeze here ok
fair enough
what I'm sure this is the first one the
first one I know for sure so this is
this a hundred and thirty means like in
South East it's coming from the
southeast
ok so what so I don't understand what
what we're talking about here so so in
the wind speed data I should get that
norm is that correct yes yes that's
correct
close enough ok ok so I'm sorry explain
to me again so this is a wind vector in
what coordinate system in the lat/long
coordinate system so right what is that
and so can I give a projection there are
those they are those the geogrid
directions the so by default until now
so this existed before we introduced
your vector it was given lat/long
numbers and unfortunately the
recommendation doesn't even mention the
direction so that that's something we
have to do to clear up what does a
function here which says give the yes so
this has been added now as a third
argument we can set your vector so what
I'm suggesting is that because it's it's
unclear what that means we changed that
to downwind vector vector and Angwin an
upwind J vector so that it explicitly
say I know in a Geo vector there is a
notion of I mean c'mon now c'mon zo
vector
so that's telling you this is a deer
vector located at this location that's
the norm and that's the direction so now
the question is what is the meaning of
this direction the direction is pointing
to or the direction is coming from you
know I understand
so that's ambiguity but a dream vector
itself normally a Geo vector goes from
there to here like it says but you're
saying for wind the convention with the
arrows no wait a minute
the convention has cut no go ahead the
convention with the artists if you go to
any site showing maps of wind they will
have the arrows flown in the same
direction of the wind it says that when
you say what's the direction of the wind
do you report the number they did the
compass direction from from what it
comes from okay
look to me it seems like we just messed
up wind vector data I mean I hate to say
it but you know it seems to me the wind
vector data should be the vector of the
wind probably as a geo vector I'm a bit
scared of changing something that may be
used in multiple places so I think well
maybe we need a different term winds geo
vector data
maybe we should retire wind vector data
and call it wind geo vector data and get
that right I think this a bit too much
and so experts will and this actually
would be better patron on wind direction
and the first thing they say is report
the direction it comes from so I think
it's correct that wind direction data
for example well sure that's fine but
that's that's the direction data but
wind vector data is asking for more than
that is as Michael meeting bird shots
because I think he was involved in the
original wind vector data he's not he's
not he has
okay um look listen to what you're
saying okay
my favorite solution would be to have a
function called wind geo vector data and
have it do exactly the right thing have
it actually generated your vector which
is unambiguous and correct then the Geo
vector would be along the direction of
the wind so to speak so that then if you
do a G of stream plot it'll just be
right imagine now the geomagnetic model
model data and is your gravity model
data they also report vectors so I think
it's better to have a consistent third
argument that says I want this hold on
so let's look at your gravity data I
mean the gravity model later yeah Oh is
a nice and she knows before it's not
correct though what's that doing there I
don't even understand that well okay
okay so um is this new yes so the idea
is that now we can have as well a third
argument your vector and it will report
the result as a vector which is very
useful for examples by the way why are
these not links here that I don't know
will investigate okay so what is this Q
vector I mean that's the right way
around right so well in the case of the
gravitational field we all agree in the
direction of the vector field there is
no ambiguity so we can set your gravity
model data
and I think it didn't you need to say
here now come at your vector location
time I'm not sure you need okay so you
know that geo gravity I'm totally
confused by the sport and earth does
that mean why is it with an acceleration
in all the directions well that's the
Geo vector Ian you changed your vector
to your vector in you so it's just a
matter of which coordinate system we are
using so this one means the horizontal
norm the direction in the horizontal
plane and then the vertical component
which is most of the vector in this case
of course right but if you write your
vector E and you then you get what you
are expecting which is the don't do
normal of that please so then you get
you see them with respect to that real
grid exactly it's the en you frame at
that location so the wind vector is
something different is that correct the
wind vector is something we are
reporting only in the horizontal plane
so it has two components but it's
basically the same idea that may not
always be the case I mean there is you
know there are winds aloft data although
I think those again horizontal winds
wind has a vertical component but I
don't think our functionality reports it
mm-hmm
no I know but for planes they have this
notion of winds aloft which is winds at
a certain altitude but I believe that
that's still only reporting X Y
coordinates not a Z coordinate I see but
I mean we should be planning for the
fact that we could report a Z coordinate
because we could report in wind speed
data we could report something which is
a vertical altitude right yeah
absolutely and what is the function now
that raises you up hum altitude was I'm
ever to start working on everything
related to elevation in vertical datums
etc so we don't have that function yet
okay your destination can do it with
with a special okay all right so I'm
sorry back to the wind thing okay so the
relevant wind vectors are en you've
actuators is that correct or am I
completely wrong no no those are let's
do things with it
mental coordinate systems people are
interested in right but you're telling
me that for wind vector data the wind
vectors that we have right now are are
what I mean there this is in what
coordinate system because this is list
so the wind so what we always had but
unfortunately in the version you have
right now it's reversed temporarily it
was always a list of two numbers that
long components of the vector so for
example if I were to say geo wind vector
data of the South Pole how much of a
mess is that gonna be no use your
position 9 minus 19
who knows so if we go okay that's kind
of weird
well even at the South Poles there's a
notion of northern and East
these are the north and east components
of the wind is that correct exactly yes
so that is the en you coordinate system
that is like a Geo vector a new
coordinate system etc actually try wind
vector data opposition come on Gia
vectoring you mm-hmm
this needs no inserts now by the way
Sushma the this stupid bug where this is
that the horizontal eye beam is showing
up is still with us
could you please report that yet again
they're often the I know I'm saying I
saw okay yeah yes um okay all right so
what are we seeing here so we're seeing
that's the location that's the direction
in the en new coordinate system
exactly so these deer victory and you
reports east first and then not okay so
what is wind vector what was wind vector
data doing before in vector data was
always reporting first north then east
but the signs were pointing in the
direction that wind was coming from
okay so when vector data was reporting
in the e a new coordinate system but the
only issue is that the thing is inverted
right and I think it will be dangerous
to flip that sign right now so my
suggestion is to keep it but in the
third argument we specifically force the
users to specify whether they wanted but
but that's different when you set up
when geo vector you actually are gonna
give them a real vector E and you aren't
you the plan is to have upwind your
vector up window vector E and you down
wind your vector and language a victory
in you so you specify which type of
result you want and whether it's a wind
or downwind hmm I see and the reason you
don't like my wind geo vector data is
that even that is not really presenting
it as an en u vector
exactly yeah we would need to steal the
third document to specify the type of
geo vector and then it would open their
way for other functions related to
various other force when the people use
to your vectors that aren't in you well
it depends if you are interested in
inside the direction if you want to see
them the norm and the direction you will
use the other one sometimes imagine yeah
it depends on what for example an input
who knows what they will have an input
well K better geo vector not the en you
so the e a new coordinate system it's
very clear that at any given point on
the Earth's surface there is an east and
there is a north right even though in at
the South Pole for example there's a
singularity in the coordinate system and
the East is kind of stupid it is but
even there we follow this the standard
that you first look at what is north and
then to take East to be the
perpendicular to that okay
north of the North Pole well you follow
the Meridian Meridian okay and that's
that's the convention at the North Pole
North follows the Greenwich Meridian
right do we say that anywhere do we
document that perhaps into your path
because this becomes important when you
have geo destinations and you're passing
things in that okay all right so okay in
the Geo vector case is it obvious what
coordinate system you're using
well it's documented and and the answer
is what what is the coordinate system
it's it's so in that case boy I just did
not think this was such a complicated
subject I thought this was going to be a
two minute discussion right by the way
the switch was still a bug that this
details is not showing up with it some
thumbnail there yeah I think that's
something Ryan does manually every
version so get it done yes um yes so
that's that's the diagram it's using
it's starting from the new frame but the
convention is bearing so it's it's
starting from north clockwise so it's
the norm and then I see I see
oh my gosh boy this is confusing it is
but we are trying to very hard to follow
the standards in this field with which
which are not very well chosen if I may
say right
okay the various comments on a live
stream that are kind of interesting here
first comment is people wanting animated
wind maps which I believe we would be if
should be able to do if you've got the
wind data we should be able to animate
it right there's nothing geo stream plot
should animate that just fine well we
have the data actually um okay someone
is pointing out here that yeah
think we're in a good position to do
this that you can make these cute wind
rosettes at different places showing um
the UM yeah we have that don't we we
have a we have a visualization function
that does that I believe it's a radar
plot if we don't have radar plot I
thought we had radar plot version anyway
okay so yes we are able to do that no
reports wind vector and temperature do
we make temperature available yes we do
air temperature data instead of having
star en you variance will not provide a
conversion function I believe we do that
right if you say geo vector if I said
geo vector of % 13 I believe that will
now give me the geo vector corresponding
to that geo vector y en you exactly yeah
it's follows there they stand out of
your position that are both containers
and converters right so commented by the
integrating satellite 3d satellite data
um it's it's an interesting thing to
have I don't know whether we've looked
at getting that actually 3d data on the
atmosphere we do have the data of the
trajectory for the satellites and then
we have this project of having flight
data and your trajectory no I understand
but this this person's comment as
Ethan's comment here is there is
satellite data from what on earth is it
from its from Doppler measurements right
of the atmosphere at different depths
which gives you I think the 3d view they
seem to have a an example here of a
typhoon um you know exactly how this
works but um yeah I mean that there is
some we should ask the the data team
about 3d
3d atmosphere data it's play not very
high-resolution it's probably not as
high-resolution most of the time as the
stuff we have from the surface but it
will be nice to have that um the very
least people can do great calculus
problems actually integrating over
vector fields and things um okay all
right so I I guess I am yeah I I agree
with the live stream comment that the Z
direction of the wind will be useful to
have and I just don't know whether
that's that's I believe not normally
available I mean I think that the the
the phrase I believe in in the biz of um
I think this is a very typical winds
aloft thing but I'm pretty sure that
those are not that that's a different
flight level but that those are yeah
they're just they're just horizontal
vectors I believe I do not think that
they have the Z coordinate um however
this does show that there is a yeah the
we could in principle if we can
represent since we can represent the
elevation here we should be able to get
the winds aloft at least at low
resolution here okay that's a future
thing all right look I'm I'm agreeing
with your upwind geo vector downwind geo
vector upwind geo vector en you down
when geo vector e and you I think
there's no other solution I'm a little
disappointed that the default is is a
little bit weird here um and I almost
feel like you know is the default ever
going to be what people want is my
question I think I started recently in
the same direction but then reading the
literature they all agree in reporting
the vector from the direction it comes
from and they get moved to put arguments
like okay fine so we're doing what the
literature says we should do exactly yes
okay fine well then let's at least make
sure that when vector data correctly
documents that it is
okay why don't we say here why don't we
explicitly say when vector data um gives
the four there's the most recent weather
station measurement well we should say I
think that perhaps a note is it's better
all right we have more space to explain
why the Seas and things in that okay
fine
all right so you'll add that yeah okay
terrific
all right let's go on to the next thing
okay I thought that was gonna let's hope
that the next one turns out to be
surprisingly easy okay positioning of
vectors yes so these when we discussed
your vector we had this discussion of
whether the vector should be located
with its beginning or center at the
location given I discussed this with
bread and he gave me this argument which
is that when you have this type of
structure if you use one either the
beginning or the end it looks kind of
tilted not not very balanced so that's
his argument to choose by default the
center which a thing is a good argument
so the question is whether in G or
vector itself with your markers in
Geographics we follow this
or we still locate the vector at its say
the point I think it should be at the at
the foot because geo vector unlike this
case where these vectors are disembodied
vectors without a base position so to
speak I mean one day we might have
vectors on you know look in Euclidean
space well maybe I'm just confused here
but but it makes a difference if you're
not even clear in space this where the
foot of the thing is makes am i confused
here
I mean no I think it's just that the
visualization for fields which is what
vector approach worries about may be
different than from the visualization of
a single vector or a few vectors which
is what we worry about in Geographics
yes I agree but isn't it the case okay
so you know in general okay okay
physics mathematical physics moment here
okay what is a you know what is a field
a field is some I mean in I would have
thought it's more kind of like there's a
base space and there are fibers and
there's something living in the fibers
which is the field and the question is
is it the case I mean you know there's
some version of this okay am I am I
getting myself confused and we have some
some function V of X you know V of X and
Y and V is a vector oh I know what the
issue is the issue is that most of the
time it's an infinitesimal thing right
yeah I mean the notion of vector field
is a tangent rather than a seam and I
would say tangent okay explain first
explain that further because I think
this is different I think it's a
different notion I think a geo vector is
a different notion because it has this
it's anchored at this particular point
well the vector field as well but if
these vectors in are located at the red
points and the aresty located at those
points I mean if they rotated you could
see them rotate them around
the red points to this is correct but
it's just a different representation do
we have Bret here by any chance no I
think he some coal okay can we get him
please um okay
what's the anchoring issue a matter of
how these tangent spaces sort of a line
as you move small amounts in Euclidean
space it being obvious I'm not sure I
don't think it matters what happens when
you move it's just a an issue of
representation of the vector at the
given point okay okay but so so it's
your proposal to change I mean I just
don't think it's right I think a Geo
vector should be anchored at a point and
then should move a certain distance from
that point or am I wrong or is that a
geo path that I should think about that
way I think we can do that for geo
vector I'm just trying to explain what
vector plus does in general and why we
started to have India vector as it is
right now but we can change a vector
well well what does she like to do now
right now it's for example in the map
you have above that map of champagne you
see the arrow is being centered at the
center of something so the center of
champagne is in the middle of the arrow
not right there exactly right so we are
discussing the centering of arrows yep
okay so the current behavior is that Geo
vectors are centered at their anchor
point geo geo vector arrows are centered
at their anchor point right yes okay so
and the discussion right now is should
that be changed
well but is this is this a feature
that's out and about already this geo
vector vector is completely new so I see
rights you know and obviously then it's
support and geo marker is completely new
I mean so the centering of the vectors
is what lists vector plot and vector
plot to by defaults I think it's gonna
look stupid look if geo marker if if
you've got a picture in the if the geo
marker is a library or something you
know we've got all these icons for geo
marker or a volcano let's say let's say
the jido marker is a volcano geo marker
don't you want the the geo vector to
come from the volcano rather than for
the volcano well I mean so let's go back
to the winds data that you were talking
about a little bit ago mm-hmm right now
so when you are getting a geo vector for
the wind at Concord mm-hmm you know the
wind isn't coming out of Concord right
transiting that area it is it is the
tangent so to speak right now it comes
in and it goes out
is there is that literature illness and
the cartography world anybody know but I
think the important thing here is to
have the freedom to let users to choose
what they want to represent and and they
have this ability of just of choosing
you see no I know that but I mean the
fact that geo marker so let's look at
the main issue is what if a geo marker
is not of a single point but instead of
a vector right is that geo position so
so for example when we use the marker
it's there it's the R is there how do
you say them the pointing part of the
marker that is locating the location
right for the default one it's the tip
but if you use like you know a museum or
something I'm not sure I mean I suspect
that it's it looks like an arrow through
the museum I mean Jim's been shot with
an arrow I mean that's what it's gonna
look like if we put it at the I mean I
don't think you're gonna have a geo
marker for you know the museum and the
arrow at the same time why not
you got volcanoes I want to show what
direction the plume of the volcano goes
in right although you and you're gonna
have to do something special there
anyway they're gonna overlap no matter
what you do with the defaults so let's
imagine that what I've got is I've got a
bunch of mountain icons which are the
mountain you know that the top of the
mountain yeah here's a good example so I
got the top of the mountain I've got the
path of steepest descent from the top of
the mountain okay so what would you like
the vector to do there should the vector
be anchored at the top of the mountain
with the base of the top of the mountain
or should the middle of the arrow be at
the top of the mountain in the in their
case you want the
you know the the foot so to speak or the
you know the start of the arrow at the
top of the mountain one would think so
right I mean but it depends on what your
vector is representing yeah okay so if
it's the instantaneous vector the
instance if it's the the local value of
the vector field at that position V of X
Y so to speak that will be I'm claiming
the most common case so in that case
what do we want it to do sorry say that
again I think the most common cases
you've got a vector field like wind
field or something or like you know some
let's say you've got watersheds and
you've got the direction that the water
is going at a particular point okay so
those are a couple of cases and that
what you'll have is is essentially v of
XY for a grid of XY values so if it's
coming from a field like that I think by
default it should be centered I kind of
am beginning to agree with you I mean
for a couple of reasons one is
conceptually you know as with the wind
it's sort of the right thing right you
know that the vector isn't really
starting at that point it's passing all
right okay all right listen I think I'm
convinced do we have an objection to
doing this then Jose or anybody do you
objected to centering the thing by
default having the geo marker of geo
vector be centered on the anchor point
of the Geo vector no no keeping okay
fine we have an interesting comment on
the live stream about making arrows have
an interpolation order and vector plots
and in other words having the arrows not
be straight inside spots I thought
stream plots did that
I mean stream plots curve but you end up
I mean there's when you get the whole
stream I don't think we have a way of
really doing curve discrete arrows
although we could because there's an
inferred vector field correct well not
necessarily not necessarily because a
vector plot know the vector plots assume
that there's a field I mean this vector
plot does list vector plots you just
give it the values but it still assumes
that there's a field right well I mean
this vector plot even if you give it an
array of vectors on a nice regular grid
it's by default interpolates the field
and resamples it to draw the vectors
okay well it's a good suggestion then um
should see what what's involved in doing
that okay fine so that was so
positioning of vectors we're agreeing to
leave it as it is okay okay okay I think
that was it for you Brett thank you very
much no Brom it's you okay we are
knitting numerator/denominator this
better be an easy one this really we
just discovered that do we forgot this
one okay so okay fine does it also do
gosh this horizontal Aybar thing drives
me crazy um yeah okay there's a question
from the live stream from Brian is there
an equivalent function for ocean current
and tide vectors well we at least have
tied data don't we we do we don't yet
have tied vectors I believe I don't
think tie data gives tide vectors um no
Luna what the heck is that
have not seen that before that's really
weird
um Sushma that's for you please report
it okay oh my gosh this is the foal
horrifyingly complicated yeah that those
are all the title components for New
York City um and a good question is can
you deduce from those title components
yes it should be possible it's the same
situation with gravitationally
gravitational field we start from the
harmonic components and then we do a
gradient it's an interesting question
whether for tide given that we're
supporting wind I mean the problem with
the tides is that we only have it we
don't have a full tidal model of the
earth we've been trying to get that for
a decade and I don't think anybody
really has that um you know a full model
that can give us just like for the in
the case of the wind we do have
something which gives us some
approximation to the full tide
everywhere
I think ocean currents there is some
better data and I don't know that we
have it at this point that's a good
question for the for the data team now
that we've got the G of excess stuff in
place we probably are ready to deal with
ocean currents so Sushma could you pass
that on to the data team please um okay
numerator denominator this better be
easy um let's see I need to update my
Doc's cuz I'm sure they're being worked
on right now um this page functions okay
while we're at it we're gonna let's
let's um just go back down here so it'll
take me a moment to update the
documentation easier than it looks so
this is not yet functional in your build
but we've added the
these three additional systems okay and
there's an example showing how to prove
one system from the other right I just
renamed for purposes of this blog that
I'm working on I just re reordered the
variables in my axiom system and I I
mean it's a obviously it shouldn't
matter these are formal variables um I
was actually going to ask you about it
because I I've copied their diversion
you have in in this page 8 oh yeah
Jonathan had a different naming ending
in C for example under so so right
that's what I've done now more recently
and that's what I'm doing for this blog
that I'm working on is um I am doing let
me just see I can pull it up I would
prefer a different version I would
prefer a version where it reads a B at
the beginning here although I don't know
whether that that a so that a hold on
let me just pull this up I think I have
a version actually in um I mean it's
quite coincidental that I'm working on
this random thing um so that's the
vision that I had for the main axiom and
I believe that I have an alternate
someplace down here um there we go
those are the two versions that I would
like to use um here let me just give
those to you ah it's quick you or do we
use a B I don't know what are we doing
for the other ones we use ABC engine
then that's probably what we should do
here um why isn't this working I'm copy
pasting and it's just not working
that's really weird um well I
okay so I have the two and in some crazy
format here I have from the lastest
fails to copy now there we go okay so
I'll send this to you it's a little bit
messed up because it's got but but those
those are intrinsic pieces here oh oh
gosh this is so if you map a to see here
instead of a P Q R we do use ABC okay
okay um I think it's uh I think that's
what Jonathan was using if you right
action Metallica was foreign actions you
get what you want okay all right okay
let me check here oh my god that just
show up looking fusing this is not also
completing properly yet okay that's
beautiful that's exactly the new form um
okay uh let's see we are ready to do the
axiomatic I mean the numerator
denominator now you are suggesting
rational functions as a page
should we just put it there on that line
numerator denominator then polynomial
remainder polynomial quotient yeah I
think we also need this a number
representation and let's just check that
it has correct links from numerator and
denominator yes it does okay so isn't
there one for number representation I
think looking at it recently about yeah
about uncertainty I think right numbers
and precision representation of numbers
well it should be here well if we don't
have a numerator and denominator of
ready perhaps it would be strange to
have a new one or with numbers a
composed perhaps well but but I mean
this should be on this page and
representational numbers why isn't why
is um it's together with number expand
the number to compose well I'm gonna put
a separate section here called rational
numbers oh I see which way I think it
should have a section for rational
numbers but that's your way way I mean
do we need then add another one for
complex numbers arguably we should have
those yes
it's not going to be a 2-minute state
well yeah it's not going to take very
long rational numbers and we need
complex numbers right um national
numbers needs numerator denominator and
numerator denominator
I believe national number operations
well and numerator denominator and
complex numbers needs r.e.m reom right
abs orgs sign in town sugar okay abs AAG
abs or does that actually exist you know
sign and conjugate you could say abs
sign and cons of it actually sign
shouldn't be a ids is before I would put
sign after conjugate actually but other
than that I think they do go together
okay all right nice I told you this
wouldn't be super hard okay
all right let's look at this axiomatic
theory things yes so the first thing is
that I've seen that Jennifer has this
third argument but it's not documented
equivalent to asking for a property and
I'm a bit concerned that we may need
that third argument for something else
yeah I don't think we need to have it
there
I wouldn't document it okay collection
of systems yes so that's the collection
we have right now yeah hopefully this
will get expanded there's this student
PK who is supposed to be giving getter
some more okay so do you agree that we
place this in a fabric order like
absolutely that's fine I can't see any
other order we could meaningfully use
right and then we are calling
multiplication I was wondering whether
this should be product I think it's a
bit more stand up to his product I don't
have an opinion what other people think
I mean I yes I I kind of agree with you
product well what what is the invert
okay so there's inverse there but what
about operations so if you were doing
arithmetic what would you have the x
operator be called multiplication I
guess and then addition if you have a
field for example yes but because here
we are talking about the genetic group
for example it may be an additive group
and then it would be plus we still call
it product all right okay change it and
then finally these I wanted to ask you
about what this is because I've um
that would it's called proof weighted
graph or is it proof graph weighted I
don't remember I see okay so it's a very
nice thing actually it's the thing that
we invented actually for this blog post
um
and what it does is I can probably show
you a picture of it um I can find it
here
isn't that a nice looking thing it uses
the betweenness centrality of a lemma to
decide the size of the dot I see so it's
the same graph but the representation is
different that is correct I see I mean I
don't know where the weighted is the
right I think it's an okay term okay
okay yeah okay uh that was our agenda
yep okay can I ask the question I mean
oh we are we rushing on a bunch of
version 12 stuff would should we look at
a few upcoming things we're rushing on
version 12 we have a few minutes here or
do we have okay um all right so sushma
where what are we at in terms of
projects actually what one thing that I
was looking at with Raj was future eyes
pages of which there turn out to be
sixteen hundred which is quite scary
um and that include a lot of functions
that are you know made it part of the
way but haven't made it all the way
through and we need to be finishing some
of those unfortunately the thing I have
here so if I can pull up Raj's um
material
see um this is a little scary this is
since this is sorted by time from first
commit okay so these are future eyes
pages sorted by time from first commit
and days since first commit the earliest
ones here are four thousand nine hundred
days okay but if we look through here I
don't know what um I mean some of the
things here are definitely you know um
um let's take a look here um recurring
it's form that was an old early one
which we say I mean that one arguably
should just be in the function
repository that was it looks like it's
pretty much finished here Wow I don't
know why we don't just put this in it
looks harmless
okay Sushma this is for you um okay and
let Raj know that that particular one so
digit get I believe was a function let's
take a look at that one I believe
yeah gets the
digit from a number I don't know whether
we care about that I think that's a good
function repository one um Ethan on
livestream is asking whether a graph now
supports call-outs I do not know the
answer that if it doesn't now it
certainly should um okay this quadratic
representation thing that's a function
repository play the power tower should
be a function repository thing so anyway
I mean these are this is from an
outrageously long time ago that these
were first committed some of these like
coordinate system data I thought we now
had that in some form yes okay so this
is probably obsolete and don't we also
have character data we do I believe in a
different form okay um count instances I
have no idea what that is it sounds very
much like a count the number of
instances that makes an expression true
huh fascinating okay well probably
something for the function repository if
nothing else mm-hmm well anyway so we've
got a lot of things here that can be oh
boy this is formal symbol that's an
early version of formal symbol which we
now don't need um local time data I
don't think we need that anymore
so there's a lot of stuff here it's
become obsolete that we can really get
rid of um and some letters
not anyway and some of this we may find
it's already been implemented and we can
just directly make use of it I'm so a
question in let's talk about um okay so
I'm looking at my list of low-hanging
stuff so mean around I can simply take
off the list because it's done right yes
just pull up a list of done ones
okay so mean around is done ah
I also have on here semantic cases which
I know we're working we need to work on
um
external value that is effectively done
right it's been done for reading from
external sources it's not been done for
writing texts okay okay so next we have
um these things here for now the host
registration data is same as domain
registration data of something and it
has been done but not documented for me
tools right I'm gonna I'm gonna remove
that for ya and consider that done um I
mean that's still a bit of a mess okay
next question is array Association which
is our whatever the version of that you
know what I'm talking about there where
you take a bunch of keys and apply it to
an array we really have got to get that
one done um what is the current status
of that one um I haven't worked on that
I think we should have I would place
this function close to data set and
perhaps you should have soon a dedicated
meeting about data set fine I'm very
strong
about this yeah at the same time Sushma
if you can organize that though
okay this virtual machine function
Christian I think is having some people
work on that although I'm not sure he
knows the definition here properly and
if you could send that to I had send
that to him sometime ago but I will
think him again about asking about I
think I think that's now current okay
okay find character encoding what
happened to that so we had an
implementation but then it was not up to
the mark ask for it I and so we have now
moved that into implementation as an
import option okay okay so listen find
character encoding should be provided in
the function Republic yeah that that is
also in my cue for function of was a
tree okay um that thing glyph graphics
We certainly have what we need to do
that I don't know whether they want to
make it I mean that's a that's a John
Folse
Roger type thing if you could just try
and ping that again I think we have that
that's just basically taking a glyph and
turning it into graphics okay what
happened to all of our column functions
well I think we never agreed on what to
do there because this involves multiple
things like the language of position
specs and what to do is extract and all
so right so I think we need to talk
about that again yeah I really support
having these column functions even
though they're special cases but I think
we need to discuss but the main problem
is that we didn't know exactly what to
do what they should do well discussion
of do they collapse full column into a
number do they not
yeah I get it I get it right that was I
remember now that was the issue so we
should try and get a summary and then do
that
okay the flattened thing this has been
postponed after version 12 it shouldn't
be too difficult to implement but okay
do we think we have the right name no
the last things we have discussed were
flattened in or flattened Apple
flattened in that's gonna be a spelling
mistake yeah um so what that's doing a
flattened into we've got listed here
also flatten a ball makes it sound
discretionary which it's not
or is it it's only flatten a ball and
list right yep
no but what about this case here hold on
we discussed something like that but
then this gets complicated when we have
hold functions in the second document I
see okay I mean there's some some the
word you know words like splicer ball
except we already have boy did we
deprecate the function splice wow that's
good
splicer ball
I'm not sure okay um
but that wasn't okay so that one is up
whatever happened to file partition and
file join that was done let me let me
check but I think that is also something
which was done is it done or was it on
the CSE agenda I don't think it's done
okay there's more to CSE because that is
why I wrote CSE there but you know I
will check again okay so this whole
business of line through circle through
that is all part of the synthetic
geometry project and I believe is done I
mean the conic through isn't done but I
don't think we're gonna get that yeah so
I'm pretty sure this is done if I'm not
mistaken can we check on that um or am i
confused is this circle through actually
okay so you know what you know what I'm
wrong this isn't done and it should be
done okay I'll send that to them so
that's for Michael and those guys okay
okay web image is done spectrogram audio
is done seola's plot 3d that that will
come soon as I said for the next cycle
we will work on on elevation India so
okay what is the fraction form I think I
see
greater denominator right oh okay fine
so that's done yes and this one is one
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute no it's not no it's
not look at this this is fraction form
this is write that as a fraction with a
certain denominator huh look it's it's
like writing for example let's imagine
you want you're making a table of I over
for I up to seven okay you might want to
write those things as two over you know
as this thing as 2 over 4 for example so
it's a formatting it's a 4 I reckon
which is why it's called form right so I
don't believe that's done now maybe we
don't care about it
I would say correct on both counts
well sort of thing that might be I think
I actually never had it in the
calculator stuff and it's cute but it's
not really fun well so let's put it in
the function plus a tree lek I say thee
what's that I say the black what's black
mean yeah you don't cut okay what is the
mixed number form that's one on one half
right writing it out as one and on that
that is the former the integer rational
part
oh I'm sorry it's also the format
version yes correct
do we have this or not not yet what we
have is the next one the integer
fractional part it's now called mixed
fraction parts
that's we have okay okay so this is
still to do this mixed number form is
still to do yeah that one strikes me as
being more desirable then yes I agree
this this is this is power trees they're
arbitrary functions what's that right
yeah the power version of any product
right using associativity appropriate I
mean that to me is a function repository
thing initially yeah this one
I really want Brett to work on this
pictogram array thing what was range
index I have no idea
let's take a look here I don't know
either okay
I mean I think we might want to abandon
that one even though we don't even know
what it is
okay bitwise function well that's a
function repository thing and that could
be put in almost immediately remind me
what this does this is the analog of a
boolean function operating it's like bit
XOR generalizing bit XOR to any boolean
function so XOR becomes any boolean
function so for instance this example
bitwise function 150 comma 3 as a
cellular automaton of that operates on 3
what that takes is eat the bits from the
numbers a B and C ok and the
corresponding bit from a from B and from
C and operates with boolean functions so
what it's doing is it's taking boolean
function 150 comma 3 ok it's 3 the
number of arguments you're yes yes it is
and 150 there is such a thing as this
boolean function yeah ok yeah I probably
might do this but luck it'll show it
there it is very neat so what that's
doing is um so I mean for example yeah
no I get it now so you want the bitwise
version yes
I mean that's a good um uh current
window images that we have that
basically Oh
molecule plot molecule plot 3d we very
definitively have those now this is
something sorry that I accomplish list
plot we we have that don't we We
certainly have complex plot
do we care about great
I feel like just for one second I I
maybe this is I really should go to
another meeting but um create notebook I
can do this write function repository
does that work
what can I say
aggghhhhh how do I do this is it in the
new
yeah function resource there we go
okay I'm um I'm just I'm just setting a
good example here should we call it bit
function it's bit X or
it's really bit boolean function just
because the analog a bit xor
Bly a boolean function two bits of
integers and I would say the
corresponding that for corresponding
bits um so and the definition here is
bit boolean function
um Ethan on our live stream is saying
what about finishing table view great
idea it is so close does this just do it
oh I wonder whether that works to be
able to say this thing that has an x and
a y there I wonder whether that works in
these definitions um
so it's a bit boolean function of let's
say I don't remember which one is I
think X or a 7 am i right
pull the N function of seven no that's
not X or that's NAND um okay who knows
what X or is wasting my time doing this
um X or will be 0 1 1 0 oh for goodness
sake that's not what I meant
6 okay so this should be equivalent to
so if I do 1 2 3 4 5 6 here and we
should get that should be the same as
bit XOR of 1 2 3 4 5 6 and it is good um
I'm putting this Sushma in my
repositories function repository now I
don't know whether that's sub Valley
formal work here that we really need to
check um so it doesn't I assume that
there has to become a pure function
there um so I assume that this gets
definition of that and it also has a
definition that says some hmm that's
complicated isn't it because if this is
comma K there um yeah so that's gonna
have to be written more carefully um but
a conditional length is K length of the
list form I mean you can insist on the
head being integer if you like I don't
know if that's actually needed well yes
we should have that on the first version
too yeah but we don't even need the
first version after we do this version
right um
length of that equals equals K and then
this thing just becomes pulling function
of n comma K and there's X comma Y is
just become X I think they become the
list X right and now
clear that boolean function does is is
bit xor ferox I don't know I don't think
so I mean I shouldn't say that
it is oh yeah it is feral yeah it is
what all the others are the bitwise okay
so this just becomes of n is a well we
really need to say there have XY anyway
this this requires a little bit more
work but but um this should now just
work here
Oh would just not work why does that not
work because look this is wrong the
default is to that's the problem I need
to go to my next meeting
I'm just goofing off here ah good
Willy's chest this guy okay let's just
test it know what happened what happened
what happened what happened bit boolean
function of 6k is 2 I'm very suspicious
that that K is blue there and in fact
what's wrong that condition needs to be
outside here okay I think a very old
scoping issue well that's I I don't
necessarily consider it wrong okay so
then if we say bit boolean function of
rule 150 comma 3 comma 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
I get that and that should be should be
right so there's a function um so this
is this can go for cleanup - I mean oh
gosh we take the 2 minutes to just write
this represents
you
no computes
you
you
the bitwise
this bit X or just says
you
puts bitwise boolean function
and if we look at boolean function wait
a minute how can this be right this is
saying boolean function of K comma N
you
what how can this be right okay boolean
function and variables Oh how super
confusing
yeah okay so this is very bad that we've
got it this way around sorry we've got
to change this you see what I'm saying
this is this is confusing that this is
everything's correct except that we got
this the K in the end of the confusing
way around here
you
you
I thought that that was the way that it
was for boolean function 150 comma 3 it
is it is it's just that n is N variables
variables wrong it was boolean function
of the integers yeah x and y and then
we've got the next case which is it was
blue in function of n comma K of and
then I don't know how we represent this
here actually I haven't done one of
these um that's definitely not right I
don't know how one does these some um
it's a good question for the ok computes
the case ah an input that was boolean
function of the integers X sub I so we
have osm properties and relations we
should say though we should give this
one
although we might want to give that in
basic examples as well
you
compute the bitwise
you
you
how does one make a
do you know how to make a separator here
that should be in here
anybody know great um that's a question
for our fine team now how do you make a
separator that should be in the toolbar
at the top I mean I can completely cheat
and I can use our separator from over
here but that's kind of not um not fair
oh it doesn't even work okay there
should be a subset for examples um okay
good good all right well thanks everyone
thanks to people on the livestream
switch from the police don't forget to
move that to take this thing over and
there's several questions here about how
this should be formatted and how how the
sub value thing works and how the
delimiter works okay to be continued all
right thank you thank you folks on
livestream also bye